le résultat d'un sondage kantar sofres
que le figaro a publié hier
pourtant depuis le départ de nicolas
hulot le sujet n'est plus vraiment au
centre de l'actualité les français
pensent qu ont-ils à mettre un à
l'écologie quand ils mettront leur
bulletin dans l'urne aux européennes les
politiques sont ils en train de passer à
côté du sujet avant d'en parler on va
regarder
l'ex ministre de la transition
écologique nicolas hulot c'était le jour
il annoncé sa démission en direct sur
france inter oui vous à l'écouté il va
parler d'union nationale et de nécessité
donc de s'unir sur ce sujet en écoutant
mais au quotidien qui j'ai pour me
défendre
est-ce que j'ai une société structurée
qui descendent dans la rue pour défendre
la biodiversité
est-ce que j'ai une formation pour les
politiques est-ce que j'ai une union
nationale sur un enjeu qui concerne
l'avenir de l'humanité et de nos propres
enfants
est ce que les grandes formations
politiques et de position sont capables
mans un autre de se hisser au dessus de
la mêlée pour se rejoindre sur
l'essentiel
est-ce que la responsabilité c'est
simplement la responsabilité du
gouvernement est ce que c'est simplement
la mienne marin de viry la raison
nicolas hulot finalement trois semaines
après sa démission aurait écouté ses
propos un enjeu qui concerne l'avenir de
l'humanité ça devrait être au centre du
débat politique
moi ce qui me frappe dans cette affaire
c'est qu'au fond l'écologie a été une
manière pour un certain nombre de gens
qui étaient sensibles à ce thème là de
rentrer en politique mais ça n'a jamais
été une ligne de partage jamais été une
véritable ligne de partage politique ne
se sont pas structurés des forces
politique idéologiquement construite
c'est au tour de l'écologie globalement
et je pense que ce que l'audi là c'est
tout à fait le reflet de ce phénomène
c'est à dire que au fond l'écologie est
un phénomène ni droite ni gauche d'un
phénomène qui concerne l'ensemble de la
société c'est un phénomène pini auquel
la société doit être extrêmement comment
dirais-je sensibiliser pour qu'ils se
mettent à avoir une forme d'efficacité
politique ce qu'il constate cette année
là bas s'il constate c'est que ce n'est
pas le cas mais je ne crois pas qu'il y
ait une forme d'écologie politique si
vous avez été vous avez été surpris par
les résultats de ce sondage qui m'est
effectivement parmi les priorités
l'écologie s'était donc 76%
revoir le tableau et puis c'est toujours
dans les premiers alors je pense que le
fait que ce soit absolument en tête
c'est peut-être aussi liée au départ du
lot parce que le sondage était juste
dans la foulée départ du locataire
mais à la limite fin mais c'est toujours
en tête mais pour qu'un pour qu'un thème
face structure le débat politique il
suffit pas qu'ils soient prioritaires
il faut comme le disait marin qui soit
clivant et pour l'histoire climat afin
qu'ils ne soient pas d'accord
or personne n'est contre l'écologie
personne n'est pour la pollution
personne n'est pour dire oui vive le
réchauffement enfin il faut vraiment
très très logiquement spécialisés pour
soutenir ce thème là donc un thème qui
est prioritaire mais pas clivant mais
pas clivant ne structure pas le débat
c'est vrai pour l'écologie c'est vrai
aussi pour le chômage les élections tout
le monde considère que la priorité c'est
plus que choquant au chômage mais en
fait tout le monde et pour qu'ils
baissent et personne ne sait exactement
comment le faire baisser
donc les élections se passent pas là
dessus pour que les élections se font
sur des choses ou qui sont importantes
aux yeux des français où ils sont pas
d'accord où il ya un camp contre l'autre
et là on peut se disputer là ça a nourri
une élection taki joyal
non mais je suis frappé dans le débat
dans d'autres sondages récents c'est
l'immigration qui arrivait en tête c'est
le haut doxa france info le figaro je
crois l'immigration en tête ça c'est
typique c'est important et c'est que les
bords mais je pense que les le personnel
politique actuel celui qui va mener la
campagne des européennes
mais il ya un lien évident à faire qui
n'est peut-être pas assez fait dans
l'opinion peu au grand public entre
migration et immigration et un chauffe
mans climatique à l'origine de ces
mouvements de transhumance et de
déplacements de populations
il ya ça il y avait déjà les maths les
guerres de l'eau qui ont commencé au
proche et moyen orient
il ya évidemment l'absence de
perspectives de débouchés dans des zones
désertiques comme le sahel
c'est ça qui fait bouger les populations
également vers l'europe et si on a
réussi aussi ont réussi si des hommes
politiques qui seront en compétition
bientôt arrive à mettre le débat ce
niveau là et pas juste sur des barrières
et des barbelés
ça deviendra très intéressant olivier
sur le il ya eu juste après la démission
de nicolas hulot
cent mille personnes réunies
dans la rue le spi 1 samedi sera le 8
septembre c'était la marche pour le
climat où c'était son intitulé
bon ça montre quand même qu'il ya une
réactivité de l'opinion assez forte
oui mais je pense que au risque de
passer une fois de plus pour l'emmerdeur
de service je pense que vous
surinterpréter ce sondage je me permet
de relever que vous agrégé la réponse
prioritaire est la réponse importante
la réponse la priorité importante les 76
% vous avez entièrement raison et bien
entendu c'est pas 76 pendant qu'ils
disent que c'est prioritaire c'est 40
aux gammes ses 41 qu'est ce que c'est
prioritaire et cinq ans et 35 important
je savais bien que vous prendriez pour
l'emmerdeur de service je m'intéresse à
m 41% prioritaire c'est pas la même
chose que 75% prioritaire donc c'est une
nuance mais elle mérite d'être fait
deuxièmement là je peux que répéter ce
que vous avez dit à l'évidence et
l'illustré à l'évidence entre
prioritaire est important ça ne pose
aucun problème à un immense majorité des
français de dire que c'est prioritaire
ou important ça impose un chouïa plus de
lui dire pour même si le chiffre est
très élevé voilà on se prend 11 points
de moins pour la reproduite à la
frontière des déboutés du droit d'asile
parce que vous avez une minorité de
gauche pour illustrer sa qui trouve que
c'est pas du tout prioritaire ou
important de reproduire les déboutés et
qui va pas dire que c'est pas important
la lutte pour le changement climatique
relativisons relative est ce que nos
internautes relativise selon vous
l'écologie doit elle être une réforme
prioritaire secondaire ou inutiles
réponse 70% prioritaires 23% secondaire
7% des loyers qu'on fait aussi dans la
précision et le détail pour betsy
l'écologie politique est à l'heure que
les lobbys ont inventé et au delà des
mers
alors qui nous dit pourquoi elle en
france l'écologie est accaparé par des
sensibilités des extrêmes de gauche 1 de
viry vous aviez dit l'écologie politique
ça n'existe pas que répondez vous à
notre internaute
donc c'est assez naturel que l'écologie
soit comme vous dites monopolisé ou
disons particulièrement enfin un thème
d'extrême gauche c'est assez normal
c'est à ce moment ça transpire gauche de
la gauche non mes chevilles il faudrait
que l'on s'accorde sur nos taxinomie
médisants à gauche de la gauche bien sûr
bien sûr
donc en fait je fais non pas simplement
l'écologie est partagé par tout le monde
pas par tout le spectre politique je
pense que c'est pas du tout clivant je
pense que ça pose pas de problème
particulier
la question est de savoir si l'opinion
effectivement pouces ne pousse pas hulot
a raison de ce point de vue là et
l'opinion ne pousse pas plus que ça en
réalité la lafa très pour le principe et
les conséquences particulières on leur
dit va du coup la voiture pourra
conduire on invite fabricant ça me
touche je suis moins pour et tandis que
quand je suis pour le principe
et puis après faut mettre les mains dans
le capot est là pour demeurer j bientôt
l'heure de vérité ça dès octobre c'est
la ppe la loi de programmation
pluriannuelle de l'énergie eon va savoir
si oui ou non à quelle date combien
d'électeurs il compensait comment par
quoi et la seo par ailleurs fils il ya
plein de façons on peut en fait pour
l'écologie et 10 rebonds le meilleur
moyen de défendre l'écologie c'est faire
du nucléaire parce qu'on veut pas dire
qu'il ya des gens qui sont à la fois
écolo qui sont contre le nucléaire
là ça redevient un débat mais dire qu'on
est pour l'écologie franchement personne
et contre l'écologie on en reparlera
sans doute les évaluations c'est en ce
moment que ça commence elles ont
commencé cette semaine pour les élèves
de 6e primaire mais aussi de 6e et de
secondes à peine mis en place ces tests
sont déjà critiquée par les élèves
semblé comprendre mais